Les nombres ultra géants
Cinq.
J’ai tendance à penser que 5 est un grand
nombre.
Sérieusement.
Quand je vois 5 cartes, je n’arrive pas
à les compter d’un regard.
Je dois les séparer au moins dans ma tête
en deux ensembles de 2 et de 3 cartes.
Je ne sais pas si vous êtes aussi mauvais
que moi…
Mais bref.
Il ne s’agit pas là de l’un des nombres
archi-super-méga-hypers géants dont je veux
vous parler aujourd’hui…
Commençons par un verre d’eau.
Le nombre de molécules d’eau dans le verre
est d’environ 10^25, soit un 1 suivi de
25 zéros.
Ça, c’est un grand nombre géant.
Un nombre super géant.
Un nombre qui est littéralement astronomique,
puisque c’est en gros le nombre d’étoiles
dans l’univers.
En fait, il y a tellement de molécules dans
un verre d’eau que, avec une grande probabilité,
plusieurs des molécules dans ce verre étaient
dans le dernier verre de Jésus…
en supposant que Jésus buvait de l’eau,
comme l’explique si bien David sur Science
Étonnante.
C’est super étrange, non ? Et bien, si
c’est aussi étrange, c’est parce qu’un
nombre aussi super géant que 10^25 est vraiment
très, très étrange…
Il représente la limite de ce que nous pouvons
calculer.
Off 1.
Aujourd’hui, nous connaissons environ 10^14
décimales de π, et je ne doute pas que dans
les années à venir, on arrivera à en calculer
10^25.
Peut-être même plus.
Mais pas beaucoup plus, tout simplement parce
que même les ordinateurs n’auront pas le
temps d’écrire ces 10^25 décimales ! Il
y a environ 10^7 secondes dans une année.
Donc même avec un milliard d’opérations
par seconde sur un milliard d’ordinateurs,
nous ne pouvons qu’écrire 10^7·10^9·10^9,
soit 10^25 décimales par an…
Donc 10^25 est un très grand nombre.
C’est en gros la limite du Big Data.
Mais, pour un mathématicien, ce n’est encore
qu’un tout petit nombre.
Même un nombre comme un googol, c’est-à-dire
10^100, c’est-à-dire un 1 suivi de 100
zéros, reste un “petit” nombre.
Oui, c’est un nombre plus grand que le nombre
de particules dans l’univers, mais un mathématicien
se contrefout complètement de notre univers…
Off 2.
Par exemple, si je prends un jeu de 78 cartes,
alors le nombre de mélanges possibles de
ces cartes est déjà plus grand qu’un googol.
Or, 78, c’est un tout petit nombre.
En fait, en combinatoire, ce domaine des mathématiques
qui cherche à compter les nombres d’arrangements
d’objets, un googol est assez petit.
On en arrive alors rapidement à des nombres
aussi archi-super géants que le googolplex…
Un googolplex est 10^googol.
C’est un 1 suivi d’un googol de zéros.
Et ça, c’est énorme.
Archi-super énorme.
Si énorme qu’il n’y a pas assez de particules
dans l’univers pour écrire ce nombre.
Et oui, il faut un googol de symboles pour
écrire ce nombre et il y a moins d’un googol
de particules dans l’univers…
Mais cette remarque ne suffit pas pour faire
justice à l’immensité du googolplex.
Off.
3 Comme l’explique très bien cette vidéo
de Numberphile, si je marche un googolplex
de mètres dans une direction, alors je finirai
par rencontrer une copie identique de moi-même.
Ça, c’est parce que le googolplex est beaucoup
plus grand que le nombre d’arrangements
de particules dans un espace de la taille
de mon corps.
Donc, juste par l’inévitabilité de la
loi des grands nombres, avec très grande
probabilité, parmi l’un des googolplex
d’espaces qui font la taille de mon corps,
il y en aura au moins un qui sera parfaitement
identique à mon corps.
Et ça, c’est super bizarre…
Après tout, si ce mec qui se trouve à quelques
googolplex de mètres d’ici est parfaitement
identique à moi, alors sa biologie est aussi
exactement la même que la mienne.
Il a exactement le même look que moi, la
même odeur que moi et il pense comme moi.
Il a les mêmes souvenirs et les mêmes ambitions
que moi.
S’il me remplaçait ici, là, personne ne
verrait la différence.
Personne ne pourrait voir la différence.
C’est si étrange qu’on en vient à se
demander pourquoi est-ce que je sais que je
suis moi, et pas lui, alors qu’il ne semble
y avoir aucun principe physique pour nous
distinguer…
Vous vous souvenez dans l’épisode 25 de
la relativité quand je vous disais qu’un
univers infini me posait problème ? En fait,
il suffit d’un univers de la taille du googolplex
pour que des problèmes sur la nature de la
conscience ou de l’individu se posent à
mes yeux…
Et là.
J’espère que là, vous commencez à avoir
la tête qui tourne en pensant à des nombres
aussi archi-super géants que le googolplex
!
Et pourtant…
Le googolplex est encore ridiculement petit
dans le royaume des mathématiques.
Passons désormais au nombre de Graham.
Dans les années 70, Ron Graham introduisit
un nombre vraiment archi-super-méga-ultra
géant.
Et tout ça pour prouver un théorème.
Un théorème relativement simple, que Ron
Graham explique lui-même dans cette vidéo
de Numberphile.
Mais je ne vais pas l’expliquer ici…
J’ai pas envie de me ridiculiser comme Matt
Parker dans cette vidéo Numberphile…
Mais je vais vous faire remarquer que le seul
nombre qui apparaît dans le théorème en
question est le nombre 4.
Et pour prouver un théorème qui fait intervenir
uniquement le nombre 4, Ron Graham a du inventer
un nombre si gargantuesque, que si vous vouliez
le mémoriser dans votre tête, votre tête
finirait par se transformer en trou noir ! Oui,
parce qu’il y a une limite physique à la
quantité d’information que vous pouvez
mettre dans un certain volume d’espace,
qui a à voir avec l’entropie des trous
noirs… bref.
Cette limite est énorme, mais ce n’est
pas plus qu’un grain de poussière quand
on la compare au nombre de Graham !
La première étape vers le nombre de Graham
est le calcul de g1, c’est-à-dire 3 ↑↑↑↑ 3.
Et qu’est-ce que c’est que ça ? J’en
sais rien.
Il s’agit déjà d’un nombre tellement
énorme que je n’ai aucune idée de ce qu’il
représente !
Off 4.
Concentrons-nous pour l’instant sur 3 ↑↑↑ 3,
qui, comme on va le voir, est déjà monstrueusement
plus géant que le googolplex.
Alors, qu’est-ce que ces flèches veulent
dire ? Les trois flèches veulent dire que
cette expression peut être décomposée en
une suite de 2-flèches :
? ↑↑↑ # = ? ↑↑ ? ↑↑ … ↑↑ ?, où
? apparaît # fois à droite.
Ainsi, le
trois à gauche veut dire que la suite de
2-flèches ne contient que des 3, alors que
le 3 de droite veut dire qu’il n’y a que
3 trois, de sorte que 3 ↑↑↑ 3 = 3 ↑↑ ( 3
↑↑ 3 ), où les parenthèses commencent
à droite.
On peut maintenant décomposer cette expression
en 1-flèches :
3 ↑↑↑ 3 =
3 ↑ (3 ↑ ( 3 ↑ (... (3 ↑ 3))),
Combien y a-t-il de 3 ? Il y en a 3 ↑↑ 3,
c’est-à-dire 3 ↑ 3 ↑ 3.
Ça y est ! On n’a plus que des une-flèches.
Que signifie la une-flèche maintenant ? Et
bien, il s’agit de l’exponentiation.
De sorte que 3 ↑↑ 3 = 3 ↑ 3 ↑
3 = 3^(3^3) = 3^27 ≈ 7·10^12, soit 7 mille
milliards ! C’est pas mal déjà, hein ?
Et bien, ce n’est absolument rien comparé
à 3 ↑↑↑ 3, qui correspond à une colonne
d’exponentiations de 7 mille milliards de
3 !
3 ↑↑↑ 3 = 3 ↑ ( 3 ↑ ( … (
3 ↑ 3))) = 3^(3^(...^(3^3))))
Ce nombre est stupidement gargantuesque ! Il
est beaucoup plus gigantesque que le googolplex
qui ne combinait que 3 exponentiations.
Ici, il y en a des milliers de milliards ! Et
pourtant, il ne s’agit que 3 ↑↑↑ 3.
La première étape du calcul du nombre de
Graham, souvenez-vous, contient 4 flèches.
g1 = 3 ↑↑↑↑ 3.
Et ça, je ne peux pas le décrire…
Et pourtant, encore une fois, ce n’est que
la première étape du calcul du nombre de
Graham.
La deuxième étape consiste à mettre encore
plus de flèches entre deux 3.
Combien de flèches ? Il faut g1 flèches
!!! Vous vous rendez compte ? g1 est un nombre
déjà tellement grand que j’ai refusé
de le décrire.
Pourtant il n’avait que 4 flèches ! Que
peut être un nombre obtenu avec g1 flèches
??? J’en sais rien.
Plus généralement gn+1 correspond à mettre
gn flèches entre deux 3.
Comprenez bien que cela veut dire que peu
importe la taille de gn, gn sera ultra-méga-archi
négligeable devant gn+1.
Et le nombre de Graham, lui, est celui que
l’on obtient après 64 itération.
C’est g64.
Il s’agit d’une construction méga débile
pour gamins qui racontent n’importe quoi
! C’est faire absolument n’importe quoi
juste pour construire des trucs qui veulent
rien dire.
Ça n’a aucun sens d’après moi.
Et je dirais même que ça devrait n’avoir
aucun sens pour tout le monde ! Là, on entre
tout simplement dans un royaume qui transcende
les maths compréhensibles… et j’en viens
même à douter que notre logique s’applique
à ces quantités déraisonnables !
Et pourtant ! Le nombre de Graham reste fini.
Et la recherche mathématique a utilisé des
nombres encore plus grand depuis ! Et le plus
fou, c’est qu’ils ont été utiles…
On a appliqué la logique que l’on a inféré
des petites quantités auxquelles notre quotidien
nous a habitué à ces quantités que nos
petits cerveaux de singes ne sont même capables
d’imaginer ! Est-ce que l’on a le droit
d’étendre notre logique à cet univers
si distant ?
Et bien, dans cette série, je vais essayer
de vous convaincre que c’est difficile d’être
convaincu de quoi que ce soit.
Je vais essayer de vous montrer que la logique
n’ai rien
de “logique”...